and the relief was instantaneous and you
know I I cried because I spent 12 years
absolutely miserable and all of a sudden
I was pain-free how I came to cannabis
about what benefits I derive from it
what kinds of things I learned from also
learning how to use the plant correctly
from my particular condition and what
they can do to try to help their
patients with their journey and we've
actually built that the fencin
compliance into our platform such that
when a payment takes place the
compliance is going to be done
automatically and so we use a ledger
based system
there's no cryptocurrency it's dollars
in dollars out but basically that system
makes it easy to integrate with
point-of-sale it makes it easy to
integrate with the Baka back-office and
banking it makes it very easy to
integrate with really anything that you
online shopping carts you can use it on
the go it's very very simple stuff the
user interface is a venmo style wallet
where the the consumer is able to
actually transact from their phone
direct from their their bank account so
there's no cards implicated in the
process that's why our system is closed
loop is to take all of the volatility
out of it it is dollar for dollar
exactly what you put in it's more like a
smart contracting system and almost
everybody on the team is actually coming
from financial institutions and just
feels very passionate about this problem
about trying to provide an equitable
solution for the the people who have
been just locked out of the financial
system and it really did if you take a
look at the economics of it you don't
change behavior by slapping a no-no
label on it that doesn't happen so the
prohibition created the black market and
this is Keanu
is Kiana the haole he is my buddy
and he has helped me with a lot of
things and dogs in general have helped
me get through some dark times of my own
actually pertaining to my injury helped
me really relearn to walk and the love
and relationship that people have with
their animals I think is what's the one
of the most beautiful special things in
the world someone's opinion may
contradict yours
why is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Alex akheon we are on-site at the
new West summit the cannabis tech
conference we are now going to be
speaking with Ashley Elsner hi Ashley hi
Ellen thank you so much for having me
I'm so excited to have you on our show
really nice to meet you yeah thanks to
meet you too what a cool background CEO
and founder of artery pay that's right
and also a fin tech expert with 14 years
of global finance law regulation and
operations experience yes damn yeah yeah
like doing financial regulatory
compliance of 600 million plus dollars
in transactions yeah so crazy stuff yeah
it was um it was a lot it's a lot it was
a lot yeah so this is why um you know
you're doing artery pay and I'm excited
to talk to you about this I mean you're
you're the right person to talk to about
this and to pioneer this to spearhead
this out oh thank you thank you it's a
very important issue and we just want to
make sure that you know you can
understand everything about your own
industry and that's completely fine and
you shouldn't have to also learn
everything about
you know the financial institution
industry to like that's not really fair
and no other industry is required to do
that so how did you even get interested
in tackling this challenge well actually
Alan I am I am also a patient
I have CRPS type 2 which is a very
gnarly type of neuropathic pain disorder
standing for so it is complex regional
pain syndrome type 2 meaning it stemmed
from an initial injury an acute trauma
to my my knee I had a really nasty
injury and developed compartment
syndrome ended up with this pain
disorder as a result of it and was on
you know a host of different medications
for years and years and years with very
little relief and really no no lasting
relief and then you know about a year
and a half ago I finally actually tried
cannabis when my father who's a
neurologist told me that the studies
were very promising that it was supposed
to be very good for neuropathic pain
disorders and and the relief was
instantaneous and you know I I cried
because I spent 12 years absolutely
miserable and all of a sudden I was
paying free and what was even more
remarkable about it is after the the
sort of euphoric effects wore off which
was relatively short-lived I had pain
relief for over 24 hours without having
to reduce and that's incredibly powerful
given everything else that I had been on
that was enough to let me know that this
was the right thing to do and just
coming in with the right background and
it became something that I'm very
passionate about and think is very
important this is a recurring theme that
we have from our guests is that there's
some sort of a big issue that occurs
with our health or our wellness and then
we're just given these solutions that
are actually don't actually heal the
root cause of the issue or that are just
band-aids that are not actually
and here we have cannabinoids and we
have this potential this incredible
potential augmentation to health and
wellness issues but that is currently
being buried and so that needs to come
to the to the light of day and see it
and like this is a great case of
yourself then yeah getting the health
benefits that you needed yes and I
actually feel so strongly about what my
patient journey has been and about this
plant that I'm going to be speaking
actually to doctors at a pain management
summit in Philadelphia in November about
this very issue about how I came to
cannabis about what benefits I derive
from it what kinds of things I've
learned from also learning how to use
the plant correctly for my particular
condition and what they can do to try to
help their patients with their journey
yeah yeah so then how did that end up
leading you into founding artery pay
tell us about this transition so I am a
as you as you spoke about I'm a
financial institution lawyer by
background I understand very well the
challenges that financial institutions
face wanting to work with the space and
I also knew that the actual challenge
did not stem from a legal challenge but
really from the cost of compliance and
the cost of working with this space so
what we did that was different is we
wanted to make sure that we had a
completely legal platform that was easy
to use easy to integrate with systems
was not going to get anybody into
trouble because that could derail
legalization which beat would be a
nightmare absolute nightmare for the
patients who depend on this plant
including myself as I've standing and
said but what we were able to do is
build this platform have it be
completely legal completely compliant
with all the fence and regulations that
are asked for and we've actually built
that the FinCEN compliance into our
platform such that when a payment takes
place the compliance is going to be done
automatically mm-hmm and there is still
you know investigations that have to go
through if there is anything that
actually looks like it should it should
be investigated but standard practice
for any any cannabis transaction is that
it needs to be reported to FinCEN and
that's just a something that since it
was going to be such a big burden we
built it into the system to deal with
operational cost him streamline the
management of these systems and to make
it easier for financial institutions to
say yes to cannabis if their only reason
really had to do with compliance
resources okay so when both banks want
to take on cannabis growers or or
distributors or dispensaries well or
when they themselves want to become
banked all those people want to become
banked that there's still a lot of
regulatory climate that is occurring and
okay so then - so to catalyze the
emergence of this this you can build
software that helps make those processes
easier yes if it does it correctly one
of the things about financial
institutions that people are not really
aware of is that the internal systems
that are used are very very outdated and
a lot of the work that gets done in
order to do compliance in order to
actually run these financial
institutions and operate them are done
by very very expensive professionals
with very specific background and is
also done manually so you have siloed
systems that don't transfer data in
interchangeably between them they don't
communicate with themselves and that
means that you have to have a person
actually sitting there taking that data
looking at it and transferring it over
to the systems that need to be running
the analysis
and that's that's a lot of work you're
talking about billions of transactions a
day yeah I mean that is a lot of work
and compliance teams are frequently
overworked as a result of that and
typically not resources with very good
tools to help them do that and in
particular the cannabis space because of
the federal prohibition that has made
many of the the federally chartered
institutions feel uncomfortable with it
with working with the space the state
chartered institutions like credit
unions community banks they have been
the ones that have been leading the
charge into the cannabis space and their
compliance teams are very lean very lean
and they also have capacity issues so I
mean it just this allows them to have
their capacity increased just from using
a software system that actually supports
the compliance processes and makes us
easier for them so the stuff that they
don't need to be looking at it's
automatically reported the way that it's
supposed to the stuff that they are
supposed to be looked at gets flagged
and reported to them for them to
investigate so that you don't have these
false positives yeah yeah and then is
this also similar to hyper at all or yes
I mean you know I welcome that
comparison hyper they do things very
well what's nice about our platform
though is it's a little bit more tech
forward we're actually using the latest
and greatest financial technology which
is actually a blockchain it's been
proven it's consistent and we are using
that as the foundation of the financial
institution so for recording transaction
and reporting transaction so it is our
internal working system versus these old
systems that are from the 1970s I don't
know if you've ever heard of COBOL COBOL
I hope you haven't it's a system that's
actually older than I am but it's never
been updated from the inside of
financial institutions this is still the
software that they're running never
updated never updated the closest thing
that you've got to an update is maybe a
better user interface from like the
1990s but this is
are all the same and all of them are
silent they don't communicate and so it
ends up being a lot less expensive to
run our systems and it's also something
that's scalable whereas the old software
systems really aren't I mean they they
have scaled out through you know
increase of servers and just huge huge
farms and more and more compliance
professionals but the software itself on
like an individual basis is kind of not
not that easy to use for scalability
which is why a lot of financial
institutions still use very clunky
systems yeah and the regulatory
frameworks are shifting okay
block Giants attractive for another
reason that I want to go into just very
quickly for finding a financial
institutions in particular you cannot
actually change the transaction records
once they've gone through on blockchain
so that's really important when you
start talking about what regulators are
looking for the immutable ledger exactly
exactly and so we use a ledger based
system
there's no cryptocurrency its dollars in
dollars out but basically that system
makes it easy to integrate with
point-of-sale it makes it easy to
integrate with the Baka
back-office and banking it makes it very
easy to integrate with really anything
that you online shopping carts you can
use it on the go it's very very simple
stuff okay so what's the core than it's
usually yeah yeah so the foundation of
artery pay that you really wanted to
make sure that you were building on top
of was first and foremost an immutable
ledger yes that's right first and
foremost the immutable ledger that
allows transparency and Trust where
there has been some difficulty verifying
records you have to be careful about
verifying the source of funds when
you're coming from cash heavy systems
gosh heavy industries and that's one of
the things that banks are very wary of
is this legacy cash that's built up into
the system and one of the things that we
are trying to help that with is if you
have this immutable ledger where they
can reconcile it back to a system that
we could not have had any influence over
as well as our records not being able to
be changed that source of fun
coming from legitimate sources is
already proven so as more financial
institutions come online you are
actually able to get banking more easily
because you're a legacy cash is is
something that can be deposited into the
Federal Reserve without any question as
to where it came from
hmm cool system so so then immediately
upon transaction at the dispensary level
mm-hmm
then our artery pay is right there yes
it's right there so it plugs into
point-of-sale yes it does it plugs into
point-of-sale the user interface is a
venmo style wallet where the the
consumer is able to actually transact
from their phone direct from their their
bank account so there's no cards
implicated in the process so there's no
there's no chance it's not Visa
MasterCard issue where they don't allow
it
that's right federally there's no
merchant category code so anybody who's
having to to try to to do that is
isthmus coding transactions which is
unfortunately it's money laundering so
then our to repay is let's not do that
it's tied to my bank account that's
right yeah and so then like venmo saw
wallet that most I'll wallet and then
they also have our to repay on the POS
is at the dispensaries that's right and
so a QR code would be displayed they
would snap a picture in the artery app
of the QR code it'll tell them what
products they're purchasing how much you
confirm the transaction and the
transaction occurs from their bank
account
yeah great I'm glad that you guys are
also using QR quick response codes yeah
it seems like China and Asia picked up
on QR codes and the u.s. kind of threw
them away for some reason so yeah I
don't have an answer for why but we're
starting to adopt it now yeah yeah yeah
good for us yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's interesting yeah being there doing
interviews recently and and seeing that
in play as a major technology and then
now hearing you talk about it and using
that in your service here makes me
actually you know it makes me like cool
I'm glad to hear that someone yeah
because I don't get to see it at you
know restaurants and transit and like
contacts and all this other kind of
stuff like they get to I think it's
coming oh hopefully maybe there's even
something yeah there's that and maybe
even something better than that that's
that's just around all around the core I
hope so yeah now then what what's going
on then on in your in your system for
just like I checked out I have a couple
items at a dispensary I'm checking out
I'm using artery pay you know it's the
on this immutable ledger so you must
have then me ask some sort of a unique
identifier yes on your ledger and then
you know that I have a certain amount of
of finances available that's right and
then you just move those numbers over to
the digital ledger of the yeah to the
unique identifier of the dispensaries
storage and then and then then this is
all in like you said in dollars this is
not even dollars that's correct this is
an exact dollars and the way that we're
able to do that as we interface with
banking we also we work with banking or
without so so for quite a few of the of
the folks in this space there has been
problems with finding reliable banking
services as well and some of that has to
do with you know certain banks deciding
that it was not for them and so clearing
out accounts some of it also has to do
with the lack of capacity so credit
unions and community banks are smaller
and for safety and soundness purposes
you really can't have your deposits come
from only from a single industry it
needs to be diversified across a number
of industries for you to actually be
able to mean
safety and soundness and the rule of
thumb that you cannot go over is about
10% there's any single specific industry
better rule of thumb is somewhere
between two and four percent if you're
really trying to prevent an economic
catastrophe from from causing your your
financial institution to close up but
that means that there is a limited
capacity for the institutions that have
actually come on board to help the space
and that's why we also are able to
actually help with the custody of some
of those assets assets outside of the
banking system and they will still have
this financial resource with the
verified verified source with the
transactions that it's coming from legal
sources even if they're unable to obtain
banking just because wait lists aren't
moving yeah okay so this works with or
without banking okay that's also unique
to our system interesting so literally
wait a dispensary can list themselves on
artery mm-hmm and then just like accrue
credits and it's held in the banking
system it's helped with our banking
partners that Capitals help with our
banking partners in the name of the in a
for the benefit of account so this is
like PayPal when it first started out
where invent Mel actually where there
was no cards attached to it you were
using it for pure peer-to-peer and
basically you were just changing who
owned the underlying assets that were
held in those accounts it's the same
thing and then when I want to withdraw
though that's when how does one withdraw
then when you're not tied to a
traditional bank work right so we can
either write a check we can also
actually cash you out if you want cash
you can have it but the whole idea is to
try to help stem the flow of cash so
that everyone can be safer physically
like you'll read a check even where do
they deposit their check
well if they don't have banking that's a
problem but they can also cash it but
that's the reason why we have multiple
options for them and eventually we
probably will be able to
that out to various forms of crypto if
they want it but you know it's not the
kind of thing that you necessarily want
to run your business on because of the
volatility and then does a does a grower
able to use artery pay yes also we are
without thinking ok you can use it for
business-to-business transactions we
work with faulty partners again to deal
with this overflow and to be able to
provide that correct bank level
reporting on the transactions that are
going on so that everybody stays
completely clean so just the the the
grower and then the the buyer who was
probably a distributor at that time
would go over with their artery pay QR
code saying that they're buying a
thousand pounds of flour yes and
eventually we'll have this hooked up to
smart contracts that will also allow
them after testing where the testing
results come back clean that it'll
initiate payments as well sure so that's
gonna be fun it goes and gets tested and
testing results come back clean and then
it's all with them yes Marc contract
yeah for it did helping to protect
everybody in the business supply chain
okay okay yeah so it also makes sense
then that artery wants the entire supply
chain to be on artery yeah as much as
possible however we're also because we
have baking partners for those who are
not banked but who are not part of the
system yet we are able to write checks
do ACH wire transfers on behalf of those
other clients it would just look like
it's coming from artery pay rather than
that client but we would memo in the
bottom so it works until we can get
everybody on the system it still works
with traditional banking until everybody
is able to get up and on the platform
but it will be much faster to do the
transfer on-boarded and probably less
expensive
as well for everyone how does artery
make money so we have a couple of ways
that we make money it's primarily off of
off of fees for transactions and that is
primarily at the dispensary level or
delivery level from the retail level we
have fees that are as low as 2% and on
the business-to-business side we have
actually have a couple of options we do
have monthly fees that you could do if
you're a larger operation and want to
opt out a per transaction fees but for
the smaller operators that aren't able
to afford some of these high monthly
fees that go along with it we are
actually doing rates as low as 100 bucks
per transaction so equivalent of a water
transfer fee okay okay and then it to be
priced for everybody yeah okay okay and
then what are you guys doing in terms of
volume of transactions right now how
many people are on boarded um you know I
have not had a chance to look at the
system recently to know exactly how much
yeah but we've got we do have
dispensaries on there we have we
actually have a partnership with the
unmould Cup coming up cool for booth
payments cool and we also have a few
distributors manufacturers who are on
the platform and have some partnerships
actually with some distributors vaulters
that's some of the vaulting partners
that were actually working with so so I
apologize for not giving you exact data
but we're doing really well
state of California is where we're
primarily located and primarily
operating but we have some more things
that are coming online soon and we also
have done quite a few integrations with
point-of-sale systems and online menu
systems so that should be coming down
the pipe and actually increase the
volume pretty pretty substantially
fairly soon okay okay and then what kind
of programming is this all made in this
is small
written and what kind of programming
language is already Oh so at this point
we're using blockchain that's an IRC 20
token we don't know that we will stay
with that forever there are less
expensive more efficient mechanisms for
transfer but this was a really good way
to get the proof-of-concept out there
and the important part is that it works
it works legally it works transparently
and it does the things that all the
stakeholders in this industry actually
needed to do it reports it records
transaction it has that transparency
built into it and you know it does not
implicate any of the things that you're
not allowed to do for this industry yet
and then does it seem like the does it
seem like what's happening with the rise
of cryptocurrency blockchain
decentralization technology does it feel
like that's going to get it's it's hard
because it's also brand new emerging
market along cannabis but does that feel
like that's gonna get stacked right into
the payments of cannabis for cannabis um
I think it depends I think when you're
talking about international companies
there can be some benefit to using
cryptocurrency rather than going through
the traditional financial institutions
because when you're talking about a
settlement time of t plus 2 days that's
a pretty long time to wait for your
currency to come back into whatever
currency you want it to be in to
repatriate your money now when you're
talking about a us-based
transaction cryptocurrency doesn't make
a whole lot of sense you have a lot of
volatility engaged in it and it does not
it doesn't really matter how quickly you
move in and out of those currencies
anything that's exchange-traded even if
it's a tokenized version that has a set
value you still have some volatility to
it that's why our system is closed loop
is to take all of the volatility out of
it
it is dollar for dollar exactly what you
put in it's more like a smart
contracting system where these are
contracts to underlying dollars
we're holding an hour basically in our
in our accounts on behalf of the
customers and that way you end up
avoiding any of the the currency risk
that you could take on if you decide to
operate in cryptocurrency rather than
dealing with traditional financial
institutions or cash and that's the
thing
cash is cash it has a very specific
value and we did not want to take that
value and have that potential disappear
or you know windfall sure maybe it will
but likelihood not really it's much more
likely not to retain its value when
you're talking about a non non variable
transfer so if you want it to be dollar
to dollar you throw a cryptocurrency in
the middle and there's automatically
volatility rather than those dollars
being worth exactly what they were worth
a minute ago sure so that's the reason
that we moved away from that it doesn't
mean that cryptocurrency doesn't have a
lot of interesting use cases it's just
when you're talking about a domestic
industry that doesn't make a lot of
sense what is the size of the team right
now
so our team has about five people on it
we may be expanding very soon we have
been working on some very cool projects
with some people and think that they're
going to be a very good fit for our team
but the you know the lead people are
myself and my my chief technology
officer which is Phil Glazer he is an
old-school IBM er who developed you know
anti-money laundering systems for the
department of defense and the FBI back
in the 80s and developed transaction
systems for Wells Fargo and Bank of
America in the 90s and 2000's and really
knows his way around FinTech into some
projects like this before and then of
course you know I was with Bessemer
Venture Partners I'm doing legal and
operations for them and Sidley Austin
doing financial regulatory work prior to
that and both of us have FinTech
experience so you know it's a really
well-rounded team in that way and almost
everybody on the team is actually coming
from finance
stations and it just feels very
passionate about this problem and about
trying to provide an equitable solution
for the the people who have been just
blocked out of the financial system yeah
yeah yeah that's kind of like this big
picture
yeah macro-level perspective is people
being locked out of the financial system
that are trying to bring forth an
emerging market and so you're not really
yeah they're operating legally that's
all there is to this I mean it's a the
problem here has more to do with
concerns over institutional risk than it
does over legality and that's something
that that doesn't really get fixed
through legislation it can really only
be fixed through changes in attitudes
changes in in perceived risk so
so actually operationally needs to be
banked legally totally okay to get
banked but regulatory frameworks in
place for that are not there yet there
is some uncertainty surrounding the
regulations I don't think there is that
much uncertainty surrounding the
regulations it's just I think that the
uncertainty has been more about do we
believe what the regulators have said to
us will the next administration come in
and flip the script on it and go back to
the previous ways of doing business and
and try to put the kibosh on this
industry I think that without without
true legalization at the federal level
you know there's always the risk that a
new administration could come in and
start the demonization process all over
again
but I think that risk is very low very
low and I think that we've already
derived social benefit in a lot of
different ways there is the the benefit
to patients there is the benefit for
justice reform there's a lot of talk
around that and will continue to be
because we are not even close to done
with that yet there is a lot of benefit
to access reform in general not just
with financial institutions but patient
care justice and there's a lot of a lot
of positive things economic benefits
that have also occurred as a result of
opening up this industry and you know
getting rid of this this prohibition
that created a black market and it
really did if you take a look at the
economics of it you don't change
behavior by slapping a new no label on
it that doesn't happen
so the prohibition created the black
market mm-hmm it's really interesting
hearing about your perspective on doing
things like making immutable digital
Ledger's for an emerging market and what
that looks like for every single part of
the supply chain
I think this yeah I think is really cool
I think that without people that are
caring about doing stuff like this it
keeps it more like a question mark
rather than having something that at
least guides people in a general
direction towards I'm figuring out how
to financially handle it so it's really
cool seeing your creative take on
financially executing it through artery
I like that a lot
yeah I'm still a lot more to unpack you
know on future on future visits into
this because there's like as it emerges
artery pave you know changes a lot and
it's gonna be really interesting to see
how it ends up yeah working out that way
is there's a question that we usually
ask at the end of our show I'm
interested here what you think
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world oh boy
should I show him to you yeah I think
you guys have probably heard a little
bit and it's not just him I actually
think that
hey I think that animals are absolutely
beautiful I think that the ocean is
beautiful I think that nature is
beautiful and this is Keanu no is Keanu
the haole he is my buddy and he has
helped me with a lot of things and dogs
in general have helped me get through
some dark times of my own actually
pertaining to my injury helped me really
relearn to walk and the love and
relationship that people have with their
animals I think is just the one of the
most beautiful special things in the
world you know he's a love bug he doped
everybody he says you're delicious he
says you had something really tasty for
lunch yeah yeah this is my little
beautiful man
Wow thank you so much for coming on to
our show on teaching yeah yes I'm very
very happy very happy to be on the show
thank you so much for having thank you
this is really a fun conversation thank
you yeah thanks for all the great work
yeah this is gonna be very interesting
to continue watching what you guys do in
the space so you better keep it up keep
it up thank you we'll do our best
thanks everyone for tuning in and
greatly appreciate would love to hear
your thoughts and comments blowing the
episode let us know what you're thinking
check out the links in the bio below to
actually check out the links of Balboa
artery pay as well also doing the West
Summit support the organization's the
entrepreneurs the artists the leaders in
your communities and around the world
that you believe in you can find our
links below to our show as well and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world thank you
very much for tuning in and we will see
you soon
it's a wrap
yeah thank you good job
[Music]